Before we jump into stuff today real
quick the 2017 david pakman show comic
book colouring book calendar has arrived
we are going to put these on sale really
really soon but i just wanted to show it
to you it is absolutely fantastic this
is no doubt the best calendar that that
we've had and those will be on sale soon
let's talk about how i am voting today i
am early voting today and i'm just gonna
talk through my ballot i know that we
can't do this for every state for every
municipality but i'll just talk through
my ballot which i know a lot of people
have asked me to do first of all who
will i be voting for for president I
will be voting for Hillary Clinton tim
kaine and that I've made clear I don't
think that comes as a surprise to
anybody number two US congressman my
choices here in Massachusetts are
Stephen Lynch vs William Burke I will be
voting for Stephen Lynch I actually like
even Lynch and that's who I'm going to
be voting for I don't know Pat if you've
made a decision on that race well I
don't vote in this uh precinct here in
this congressional is right but I am
familiar with Lynch because he ran for
Senate yeah uh and lost to add marquee
but he's often perceived as more of a
centrist Democrat yeah I he it's not so
much because he's like the ultra
progressive guy that I like him but I
believe that he does a good job and I
find him to be by and large honest and
this is my first time voting in anything
a local here in Boston used to vote in
western mass and including during my
time in New York and I will be voting
for Lynch for mass state senator and
state representative there's two
Democrats running unopposed you would
have no idea who they are it would make
no difference whether I vote for them or
not and I I can just skip that I mean
that there's nobody running against them
County Sheriff here in Suffolk County
Steven Tompkins is running unopposed
again unopposed doesn't make a
difference whether I vote for Stephen
Tompkins but the entire concept of
elective sheriff's to me I guess I kind
of get it because different sheriff's
can have as we've seen from sheriff joe
arpaio in maricopa county arizona
sheriff's can go about enforcing law
differently but you would like to think
that it should be non-political to be
sheriff although that's obviously not
the case yeah you think that would fall
under the judicial branch
there's even places where we elect
judges here that's been strange yeah III
have to tell you I don't love it and I
will be just not voting he's unopposed
anyway I'll leave it blank it doesn't
matter the most interesting thing going
on on my ballot here in Massachusetts
which I will be voting on uh later today
are the four ballot questions and I have
thought about these and I'm decided on
three and there's one I'm undecided on
question one here in Massachusetts would
authorize gaming establishments with no
tables meaning no poker no blackjack and
up to twelve hundred and fifty slot
machines I'm voting no on this the slot
machine rooms are super depressing they
do provide some jobs but uh they they
really are uh is a cesspool of
depression and gambling addiction and I
don't like it whatsoever and
interestingly one of the reasons that
cited here in Massachusetts to vote in
favor of the slot machine room is that
12 million dollars will go to support
horse racing in Massachusetts that's an
argument in favor for me that's an
argument against I don't want horse
racing and if I can prevent horse racing
by also voting against slot machines I'm
definitely voting know where you on this
one I'm also know but I'm not too
particularly passionate about this issue
honestly I know that gambling does seem
to take money away from people who are
addicted and the poor saw that that's
why I'm gonna be voting no charter
schools is question number two here in
Massachusetts I'm actually unsure about
this and I know that typically
progressives vote against more money for
charter schools and a yes vote would
allow for approving more charter schools
in Massachusetts and expanding charter
school enrollment I'm leaning towards no
the only thing that's making me hesitate
is a few people that I know who are
progressive and I and I generally trust
have said because of the specific
circumstances of public and charter
school in Massachusetts this is actually
a good thing because it will not only
increase educational options but it
would it will in in some way put
pressure on public schools to improve
the opponent's though have said to me
that this is actually a bad idea it will
lead to a death spiral for public
schools because schools are funded based
on the number of students that attend
and if you make it easier for students
to go to charter schools which
not everybody can do for different
reasons you're going to hurt the public
schools whether you want to or not and
it will be even worse for public schools
yeah I'm really just against charter
schools in principle it seems to take
away finances from public schools and
sometimes charter schools will just
close down half way through school year
question 3 in Massachusetts would
prohibit any farm owner or operator from
knowingly confining breeding pigs calves
raised for veal or egg-laying hens in a
way that prevents the animal from lying
down standing up fully extending its
limbs or turning around freely I'm
voting YES on this now you might say why
would you vote against better treatment
of animals the argument that is being
made is this will make it more expensive
for farmers to do business and thus eggs
and meat are going to be more expensive
uh I don't know that I buy that and if
it's true it would be a very small
difference and I think that that's a
price I'm willing to pay I know that
could be different for everybody I'm
guessing as a vegan pad you don't care
if the price of eggs in veal goes up no
I don't really care this would actually
only affect one farm in Massachusetts
because all other ones allow their
chicken so free range is that right yes
only one farm didn't know that well then
I'm definitely voting yes i was already
voting yes and question for allowing for
recreational marijuana obviously I'm
voting yes it has nothing to do with me
wanting to smoke weed it has to do with
all of the obvious realities I've talked
to you about in relation to the legal is
it legalization of marijuana of war on
drugs etcetera I'm sure pat as you said
a few weeks ago you're still on the yes
side here yes I'm on the yes campaign
despite the scare tactics that we see
coming out of the alcohol industry yeah
which we've covered so that's my ballot
I'm voting today and getting it out of
the way